[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Live Coding,
a machine learning model
from scratch.
My name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Cloud Platform Team,
focused on machine learning.
You can find me on
Twitter @SRobTweets.
And most recently, you can find
my blog at SaraRobinson.dev.
So let's dive right in with
what we're going to cover today.
I'm going to start out with
a quick overview of what
machine learning is.
Then I'll talk about the
model we'll be building.
And finally, we'll get
to the live coding.
So at a high level, what
is machine learning?
I really like this definition--
using data to answer questions.
The idea here is that as we
provide more and more data
to our machine learning
systems, they'll
be able to improve and
generalize on examples
that they haven't seen before.
So we can think of almost
any supervised learning
problem in this way.
We have our label
training inputs.
We feed them into our model, and
our model outputs a prediction.
Now, these training inputs
could really be anything.
It could be the text
of a movie review,
and our model could be doing
sentiment analysis to tell us
that this is a positive review.
It could be numerical or
categorical fitness data,
and maybe our model predicts
the quality of the sleep
that we'll get.
It could be image data.
So in this example,
our model is predicting
that this is an image of a cat.
So this model concept
can seem really magical,
but it's actually not magic.
Under the hood, it all boils
down to matrix multiplication.
So if any of you
remember y equals
mx plus b from your
algebra classes,
this might look familiar.
The idea here is that you have
your features as matrices.
Those are your
inputs, and then you
have the thing you're
trying to predict.
And then you have these
weight and bias matrices.
And when these are
initialized, they're
initialized to random values.
So the idea here is that
as you train your model,
you'll find the optimal values
for these weight and bias
matrices, so that you get
high-accuracy predictions.
So that sounds
great, but you might
be thinking the
examples I showed
on the previous slides-- none
of those had matrices anywhere.
Well, it turns out that you
can represent pretty much
any type of data as a matrix.
So this image, as an example.
All an image really is is
just a bunch of pixels.
And this is a color image.
So each pixel has a red, green,
and blue value, or an RGB
value.
So this image becomes three
matrices of the RGB values
for each pixel.
Let's say you have
categorical data.
So for a particular
column in your data set,
it describes the industry
that a person works in.
And there's three
possible values.
The way you encode categorical
data is through what's
called one hot encoding.
So to do this, you
create an array
with the number of
elements corresponding
to the number of categories
you have-- in this case, 3.
And all of the values are
0, except for a single 1.
And the index of that 1
corresponds with the value
of that category.
So maybe you're
thinking, wouldn't it
be easier if we just numerically
encoded these Healthcare
1, Finance 2, Retail 3?
We could do that,
but then our model
would interpret these as
continuous numerical values.
So it would assign
higher weight to retail.
It would say retail is
greater than finance, which
is greater than health care.
And we want our model to treat
all these inputs equally,
which is why we one
hot encode them.
So I've shown you
how we can transform
our data for our
machine learning models.
In this talk, I want
to share with you
some tools on Google Cloud that
can help you build ML models.
And I like to visualize this as
a pyramid, where you can choose
your level of abstraction.
If you want to get down
to the details of matrix
multiplication and
building all the layers
for your model from scratch,
which we're going to do today,
you can do that.
But you also don't need ML
expertise to get started.
So the tools on the
bottom of the pyramid
are targeted more towards data
scientists and ML engineers.
And as we move
towards the top, these
are targeted towards application
developers that may not have
machine learning expertise.
So in this talk, we're
going to be building
a model with
TensorFlow, and we're
going to deploy it
on Cloud AI Platform.
The idea here is to turn you
all into data scientists and ML
engineers.
So when I was thinking
about the type of model
I wanted to build
for this, I wanted
to choose something that would
resonate with developers.
And as a developer,
there's one tool
I can think of that I
use on a daily basis,
and that is Stack Overflow.
So I wanted to build a
text classification model
to see if we could predict
the tags of a Stack Overflow
question.
To do this, we
need a lot of data.
And luckily, we have a
public data set available
in Google Cloud BigQuery,
which is our big data analytics
warehouse on Google
Cloud Platform.
BigQuery has lots of really
interesting public data
sets for you to
explore and play with.
And they happen to have one
of Stack Overflow questions,
and it doesn't have just a
few Stack Overflow questions.
It has over 26 gigabytes
and over 17 million rows
of questions.
So this is a great
place to get started.
Since we don't
have a ton of time,
I wanted to simplify
the problem space.
So in this example,
we're just going
to be classifying questions that
have these five tags related
to data science and
machine learning.
So for this particular
question, our model
should categorize
it as Pandas, which
is a Python library
for data science.
So our first step is to
get the data from BigQuery.
BigQuery has a great web UI,
where we can write SQL directly
in the browser, get our data,
and then download it as a CSV,
which is what I did.
So I'm extracting the title
and the body of the question,
concatenating them
into one field,
getting a comma-separated
string of the tags.
And then we're only getting
questions with these five tags.
So I ran this query, and as
I was looking at the results,
I noticed something.
A lot of the
questions, the question
posters conveniently will put
the name of whatever framework
they're using in the question,
which is very helpful.
But that got me
thinking, do we actually
need machine learning for this?
Could we just replace our entire
ML system with an if statement?
If TensorFlow is
in the question,
tag equals TensorFlow.
The answer is no.
Because although lots of
question posters do this,
there are a lot of people that
post questions that are really
good questions, but they just
dive right into the code.
And they may not mention
the framework or tag name.
So we want to capture
these questions, too.
And we don't want our model to
just pick up on those signal
words so that it only
identifies questions
with the word TensorFlow
in them as TensorFlow.
We wanted to be able to
generalize to find patterns
among these tags.
So when I was
pre-processing the training
data, what I wanted
to do was take out
these obvious keywords.
So I thought I could replace
them with a common word.
And because everybody
loves avocados,
I replaced all of
these words, including
abbreviations for
the frameworks,
with the word avocado.
So the results in BigQuery
look something like this.
We have our questions.
We have avocado
predictive models.
We have avocado data sets.
Lots of avocados everywhere.
So what I didn't
talk about before
was how we encode freeform
text data into matrices.
There's a couple of different
approaches for doing this.
I'm going to use one
called bag of words.
This is a really simple
one for getting started.
So you can think of
each input to your model
in bag of words as a
bag of Scrabble tiles,
whereas instead of a
letter on each tile,
you have a word on each tile.
So this type of model cannot
detect the order of words
in a sentence, but it can
detect the presence or absence
of certain words.
So to show you how this
works, I want to show you
a really simple example.
So for this example, we'll limit
our problem space even further
to say we're only
tagging questions
with three types of tags.
And bag of word models have
a concept called vocabulary.
So pretend for a
moment that you're
learning English
for the first time,
and you only know
these 10 words.
That's how our model is
going to look at the problem.
It might lead to some
interesting conversations,
but pretend we only
know these 10 words.
So when we take
this input question,
how to plot data
frame bar graph,
we'll look at our vocabulary,
and we'll say, OK.
I recognize these three words.
The rest of the
words in the question
are going to be
gibberish to the model.
And when we feed all of our
questions into our model,
we want to feed
them in as matrices
that are the same size.
So what we do is our
question becomes an array
the size of our vocabulary,
with ones and zeros
indicating which words from
our vocabulary are present.
So because dataframe is the
first index in our vocabulary,
the first element of
our array becomes a 1,
even though dataframe is not
the first word in our question.
Same goes for graph and plot.
So to summarize,
our question becomes
a vocabulary-sized
array of 1s and 0s.
It's called multi hot encoding.
And our prediction-- since
for this particular model,
our model's going to be able
to identify a question that has
multiple tags, not just one.
So this will also be
a multi hot array.
So now we know how to encode
our text data for our model.
What does our model
actually look like?
So the input data
to our model is
going to be that
vocabulary-sized bag of words
matrix.
And then we feed that into
what's called hidden layer.
So this is going to be a
deep neural network, which
means that we have layers
in between our input
and our output layer.
So it's going to take this
vocabulary-sized array
and resize it to
whatever size we
choose for our second
layer and our third layer.
Now, the output of
these hidden layers
doesn't mean too much to us.
Our model's using
it to represent
complex relationships, but
what we really care about
is the output of
our final layer.
There's many options
for how you can compute
the output of this layer.
We're going to choose
one called sigmoid.
And what this will do is it will
return a value between 0 and 1
for each tag, which
corresponds to the probability
that that tag is associated
with this question.
So for this
particular example, it
looks like the question has
a high probability of being
about Keras or TensorFlow.
So what are all the tools we're
going to use to build this?
I already showed you how we
use BigQuery to gather our data
and downloaded the CSV.
We're going to use three
open source frameworks
to do some pre-processing
and some transformations
on our data to get it
into the right format.
We'll use Pandas,
Scikit-learn, and Keras.
We'll use TensorFlow
to build our model,
specifically tf.keras.
We will run our training
and evaluation in Colab.
Colab is a Python notebook
that's cloud-hosted,
and you can run
it in the browser.
It's totally free
for anyone to use.
And finally, we'll deploy our
model on Cloud AI Platform.
So the title says Live Coding.
Let's go over to the demo.
Can we switch to the demo?
Awesome.
So here we have
our Colab notebook.
It's connected.
Again, anybody can access
Colab in the browser.
Colab.research.google.com.
And as you can see, we've
got no code in here.
What could go wrong?
Just a bunch of comments.
So I'm going to start
writing some code
and run these cell by cell.
So what I'm going
to use is Colab
has this handy snippets tool.
So I've saved a couple of the
snippets for this notebook
that I'm just going
to drop in here.
So the first one is we are
going to run this anyway.
I had to reset the runtime,
and now we are connected.
So our first cell
is just importing
all of the libraries
we're going to use.
We're using TensorFlow,
Pandas, NumPy,
a couple of Scikit-learn
utility functions,
and then we're using
Keras to build our model.
So we've got all of our imports.
Let me actually make
that just a tad bigger,
so that you can all see.
The next thing we want
to do is authenticate.
Here we go.
So Colab also has a handy
authentication function
that we can run.
And what this will do is
it will pop up a URL for us
to authenticate to
our Cloud account.
So I will allow access, copy
this code, and paste it in.
So now, we are authenticated.
And now, we're going to
get to the fun stuff.
So first, we want
to download our CSV.
So now that I'm
authenticated, I have
saved all this data in a
CSV in Google Cloud Storage.
That's our object storage
tool on Google Cloud Platform.
So I'm going to download the
CSV to my local Colab instance.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to use Pandas
to read this CSV in.
So let me just read it in, here.
And this will transform
our data into what's
called a Pandas Dataframe,
which you'll see in a moment.
The next thing
we're going to do is
we're going to shuffle our data.
And this is a really important
concept in machine learning.
In case your data was
in any sort of order
before, you want to make
sure that you shuffle it.
And I'm using the Scikit-learn
shuffle function to do that.
Data.head will let
us preview our data.
So this is what our
data looks like.
We've got our tags as
comma separated strings,
and we've got our question
text with lots of avocados.
Now, we can't feed this in
its current form to our model.
So we're going to need
to do some encoding.
So first, we'll take
care of the tags.
So the first thing we want
to do is encode these tags,
as we saw on the slides, to
multi hot five element arrays,
because we have
five possible tags.
So what I'm doing
in the first line
is I'm splitting each tag
into an array of strings.
And then I'm using this
Scikit-learn multi label
binarizer function,
which will take
all of those arrays of
strings and transform them
into a multi hot array.
So this is for the
first question.
We can see it's about
TensorFlow and Keras.
And here's this reference
array that Scikit-learn
has created for us.
So our input becomes this.
We've encoded our labels, and
we are almost ready to move on
to the questions.
Before we do that, we
need to split our data.
So another important
concept in machine learning
is train/test split.
So we take the
majority of our data,
and we'll use it for
training our model.
In this case, we'll do 80%.
We set aside a smaller
portion of our data
to use for testing
so that we can
see how our model performs
on data that it has never
seen before.
So in this case, we have 150,000
questions in our training set
and 37,000 in our test set.
So we will now split our labels
into training and test sets.
And we'll say test tags
equals tags encoded.
We'll run that.
So we've got our
labels ready to go.
And the next thing
we want to do--
our label data is ready to go.
Now, we need to encode
our question data
into bag of words matrices.
So I've written a
class to do this.
I'll paste that in here.
It looks like a lot going
on, but I'll explain.
So what's happening here
is we're using this Keras
Tokenizer utility.
So luckily, we don't
have to do all that code
of converting our freeform
text to bag of words by hand.
Keras has this utility
that'll do it for us.
All we do is pass it
our vocabulary size.
So in the super simple
example that I showed before,
we had a vocabulary size of 10.
So that will take the top
10 words from our data set.
Since this data
set is way bigger,
I chose a vocab size of 400,
which you'll see in a moment.
So you want to choose
something that's
not so small that it only
identifies common words
across all of your questions.
But you also don't
want to choose
something that's too big
that your bag of words
arrays become all 1s.
So we'll run this.
And now, we're actually
going to use that class.
So we will import it, and
we will split our questions
into train and test sets.
So I'll do that.
Right now, there's
still strings.
We haven't encoded them yet.
So the next step is to
instantiate a vocab size
variable, which is
going to be 400.
And now, we will actually
tokenize that text.
So we're going to create a
variable called processor
and instantiate that text
pre-process or class,
passing it our vocab size.
And now we can call
processor.create_tokenizer
and pass it our train questions.
That's this method, right here.
And then finally, the last
part is actually creating
those bag of words matrices.
So this will be equal to
processor.transform_text,
that method right there.
And we'll pass that
our train questions.
And then the test
set will be the same
with our test questions,
which we defined up here.
So I'm going to run that.
It's going to take a bit of time
to run, because what it's doing
is it's transforming all
180,000 of our questions
from text to bag of words.
So while that's running, we can
keep writing the other cells.
And they'll run when
this one completes.
So what I want to do
is print the length
of the first instance.
It should be 400.
And then we're just going to
log that bag of words matrix
so that you can see it.
And now, we get to
building our model.
We'll come back to this
when it finishes running.
So the next thing
that we want to do
is save that tokenizer
that we created,
because we're going to need
it when we deploy our model.
We're using a Python
utility called
Pickle to save that
tokenizer object to a file.
So now, it's time
to create our model.
We've transformed our data.
We've saved our tokenizer.
Now, we actually want
to write the code
to our model using Keras.
I'm going to wrap
this in a method.
We'll call it create_model,
and it will take our vocabulary
size and our number of tags.
And we're going to use the
Keras sequential model API to do
that, which I imported above.
This is my favorite API
for building models,
because it essentially
lets you define your models
as a stack of layers.
So you'll see that the
code we're about to write
will correspond really
nicely to that model diagram
that I just showed.
So it looks like this
cell finished running.
So we can see that this is what
the first bag of words input
looks like for our first
question, this array of 1s
and 0s.
So let's continue
building our model.
So the first layer
to our model is
going to be a dense,
fully connected layer.
That just means that every
neuron in the input layer
is connected to every
neuron in the output layer.
We need to tell our
first layer what
the input shape is going to be.
In this case, it'll be the
input of our vocab size, which
is 400.
And then finally, we
need to tell Keras
how to compute the
output of this layer.
The great thing
about Keras is we
don't need to know exactly how
this activation function works
under the hood.
We just need to know the correct
activation function to use.
So in this case, relu
is what we'll be using.
We'll add one more hidden layer
also with the relu activation
function.
We don't need input shape
here, because it will infer it
from the previous layer.
So far, these are
our hidden layers.
So we don't care too much about
the output of those layers.
But what we do care about is
the output of our final layer.
And that layer is going
to have five neurons.
It'll be a five-element
array, since we
have five tags in our data set.
And the activation function
here will be sigmoid.
So that's really all
the code for our model.
Just four lines of code, we've
defined our model in Keras.
We need to run model.compile
so that we can actually
train and evaluate this model.
And to do this, we need to
tell it a couple of things.
So we need to tell
it our loss function.
This is how Keras will compute
the error of our model.
So every time it
runs training, it
will use this
function to say, OK,
what was the error between
what the model predicted
and the ground truth--
what it should have predicted?
Again, we don't
need to know exactly
how this particular loss
function works under the hood.
This is just the best one to
use for this type of model.
I also need to tell
it my optimizer.
The optimizer is
how the model will
update the weights after it
goes through a set of data.
And then finally,
I want to tell it
how to evaluate my
model as its training.
And we're going to use
accuracy as a metric here.
So I will return my
model, and now we'll
actually create our model.
So we'll call create_model.
We'll pass it our vocab
size and our num tags.
And then we can use this
model.summary method
to see what our model
looks like, layer by layer.
So we can run that.
We've got our model ready to go.
We have not trained it yet.
So the next thing we'll do
is we'll train our model.
And we can do that with one
method call, just model.fit.
We pass it a couple of things.
We pass it our bag
of words array.
That's our input, our features.
We pass it our labels.
Those are the tags,
which we've encoded.
We need to tell it how many
epochs to run training for.
What this means is that this is
how many times our model will
iterate over our
entire data set.
So we'll go through our
entire data set three times.
Batch size is how many elements
our model will look at one time
before it updates the weights.
In this case, we'll use 128.
And then I'm going to
pass an optional parameter
called validation
split, which will
take 10% of our training
data and evaluate it
as our model is training.
So we're going to
run training, and it
should train pretty fast.
And what we ideally see
here is that our validation
and our training
loss is decreasing.
So that's a good sign.
We've got our validation and
training loss decreasing.
If your validation loss is
increasing as your training
loss is decreasing,
it might be a sign
that your model is learning
the training data too closely.
We can see that our accuracy
is 96%, which is pretty good.
So next step is
evaluating our model.
So that 20% of the
questions that we set aside,
we're now going to see how our
model performs on that data.
So we call model.evalute.
We pass it our test bag
of words, our test tags,
and we tell it our batch size.
And our evaluation accuracy
is very close to our training
accuracy, which is a good sign.
And then the last
thing we want to do
is save our model to a file.
Keras uses the H5 file format.
So we'll save our model.
And now, we're going
to test it out locally.
So we have a custom prediction
class that I've written,
and all this is going to
do is pre-process our data.
So it'll instantiate our
SavedModel from the file.
It'll instantiate our tokenizer.
It'll take the question
as text, transform it,
and then return a prediction--
that sigmoid probability array.
So let's save some
questions to predict.
This is just an array
of two sample questions.
And then we will make a
prediction on our local model.
So this should return.
Cool.
So for the first
question, it predicted
Keras, which is accurate.
The second one predicted Pandas.
So we've got our
model working locally.
Accuracy is 96%.
Next thing we want to do
is package and deploy it
to AI Platform.
So I've written some
code to do this.
And one of the
features that we're
going to make use of that's
new to Cloud AI Platform
is Custom Code,
which lets us write
custom server-side Python code
that's run at prediction time.
Now, this is really
useful, because it'll
let us keep our
client super simple.
So our client will just
pass the text to our model.
We don't want to have to do any
transformations on the client.
We'll pass our
text to the model.
And on the server, we'll
transform that text
to bag of words and then
return the correct tags.
So to do this, we'll need to
copy some files to Google Cloud
Storage so that Cloud
AI Platform can find
our model and our tokenizer.
I'm going to use the
Google Cloud CLI G
Cloud to set my current
project to the one I've
configured for this demo.
And finally, we want to
deploy this to AI Platform.
So here's the deploy command
that we're going to run.
We're going to set our minimum
nodes to 1, so that our model
doesn't scale to 0.
And I'm going to create a
new version called io19.
And we are going to deploy that.
That'll take a couple
of minutes to run.
But if I look over here in the
Cloud AI Platform model UI,
we can see that my
model is deploying,
which is pretty cool.
So while that's deploying,
let's go back to the slides.
So we built something
that looks pretty good.
We've written some code
to pre-process our data.
We've trained a model
with pretty high accuracy,
but can we do better?
Right now, our model is
pretty much a black box.
We don't know how it's
making predictions.
We know that the
predictions are accurate,
but we don't know what's making
it make those conclusions.
So as Sundar mentioned
in the keynote,
we want to make sure that
our model is using data
to make predictions
in a way that's
fair to all of our model users.
To do that, we need to
uncover the black box.
And as model builders,
we need to remember
that we're responsible for
the predictions generated
by our model.
This may sound really
obvious, but we
need to take steps to
avoid bias by making sure
that our training
data is representative
of the people that
are using our model.
Luckily, there's a lot of great
tools to help you do this.
I'm going to look at one
open source tool called SHAP.
And what SHAP will let us
do is interpret the output
of any machine learning model.
So we'll use it here
for our tf.keras model,
but we could use it
for any type of model.
The way SHAP works
is we'll create
what's called an explainer
object, passing in our model
and a subset of
our training data.
And then SHAP returns
these attribution values.
So what the
attribution values are
is positive and negative
values indicating
how much a particular
feature impacted
our model's prediction.
So let's say we had a
model with three features.
We'd get back a three-element
array of attribution values.
High positive values mean
that particular feature
pushed our prediction up.
Negative values would mean it
pushed our prediction down.
Well, how will this work
for our bag of words model?
So what I configured
SHAP to do was
I had it treat that
400 element vocabulary
array as 400 features.
And so we get back 400
different attribution scores,
and we can take the highest
values from that and the lowest
values to see which words had
the most impact on our model.
So I wrote a little
code to do this.
I don't know if the colors
are showing up well, in there.
But what this is is I
took the top five highest
and lowest attribution
scores so that I
could see which words our model
was using to make predictions.
So this particular
question is about Pandas,
and it picked up on the words
column, dataframe, df, series,
which is good, because
those are all words that
are specific to Pandas.
Words that contributed
least were for,
each, and you, which
are fairly common
words that you might find in
any Stack Overflow question.
So this is a good sign that
our model is working correctly.
So let's go back to the demo
and take a look at SHAP.
So it looks like our
model finished deploying.
I'm going to go ahead and set
that as the default version.
And before we get into SHAP, we
will generate some predictions
on our deployed model.
So I'm going to write a file
with some test predictions.
And now, we're going
to use the Google Cloud
CLI to get some predictions
on our trained model.
So we call gcloud
ai-platform predict.
We pass it our model name,
which is stacko_model.
And we pass it our
text instances,
which is this predictions.txt
file that we just saved.
And we will run that.
And now, we are going to print
our deployed model predictions.
So it looks good.
We're calling our model that's
deployed on AI Platform,
and it has predicted
Keras successfully
for the first question and
Pandas for the second question.
So now, let's use SHAP
to explain our model.
So SHAP does not come
pre-installed in Colab,
so we will install it via PIP.
And then we will also
install this module
called Colored, which I use
to color different words
of the text.
So once that's done installing,
we will import SHAP,
and we can create our explainer.
So we will create what's
called a deep explainer.
SHAP has many different
types of explainers.
We're going to use
the deep explainer,
and we're going to pass it a
subset of our training data.
And then we will create our
array of attribution values.
So we can call
explainer.shap_values.
And we pass it a subset
of our test data.
In this case, we'll
just take the first 25
examples from our test set.
So we've got our
attribution values.
The next thing you want to do
is print them in a nice way.
So first, to do
that, we're going
to take that tokenizer that
we created in Keras, which
is a dictionary, and we're
going to convert it to an array
so that we can take our
attribution values from SHAP
and see which word
they correspond to.
So we'll convert our
tokenizer to a word list.
And here, we can see the top
most frequently occurring words
that our model
vocabulary is using.
And the first
thing we want to do
is print a summary plot, which
is a method we have in SHAP,
to see a summary
of the words that
are most impactful on
our model's predictions.
So we'll pass it
our SHAP values.
We'll also need to pass it
our feature names, which
is that word list
we just created,
along with our class names,
which goes all the way back
to our tag encoder.
So if I wrote that correctly,
we should get this nice plot,
here.
And what this tells us is
the highest magnitude words
that our model is looking at.
So it looks like
dataframe was the word
that our model used most
to make predictions,
probably because there
was the most Pandas
questions in our model.
And we can see that dataframe
was most impactful for Pandas.
It was also a signal word for
the other libraries, probably
a negative signal word.
And then we can see the other
words that were impactful here.
So plot was most important
in Matplotlib predictions,
which makes sense.
And we can see all these
other words down the list.
So that gives us a
nice at aggregate
view of how our model
is making predictions
for this particular data set.
And now, if we want to
highlight individual words,
I've written some code to
do that so that we can see,
for a particular
question, which words
are signaling predictions.
So here's an example
of a Pandas question.
The words column, a lot
of Pandas dataframes
have columns that have
not a number of values.
And then we see
common words like use
and does are not being
used by our model
to make the predictions.
For TensorFlow,
we got it looking
at words like session,
sesh, ops, tensor.
Here's a Keras example.
It looks like the
most common words are
LSTM, layers, dense, et cetera.
So now, we can
see how we can use
SHAP to make sure that our
model is behaving correctly.
One way you might want to use
this in a fairness example
is if you have a model that's
doing sentiment analysis,
you want to make sure that it's
using the right characteristics
to predict positive and negative
things in whatever type of text
you're using.
So if we could, go
back to the slides.
To wrap things up, we're
going to put this all together
and get predictions from
our model in a web app.
So it'd be really
useful if we could,
as we're typing a Stack
Overflow question,
see which tags are
associated with it.
So with the help of my
teammate Jennifer Person--
you should follow
her on Twitter--
we built a Chrome extension.
And what the Chrome
extension does
is it takes the HTML of our
Stack Overflow question.
It passes it to
a Cloud Function,
which I've written using the
Cloud Functions Python runtime.
The function will use the
AI Platform API to make
a prediction on our model.
And then in our
function, we'll return
just the name of
high confidence tags
back to our Chrome extension.
So let's see it in action.
Whoops.
Let's go back to the demo.
Here we go.
So here is an example question
about Matplotlib in Pandas.
I have just loaded up my
Chrome extension, locally.
Looks like it's not
working at the moment.
Hold on one second.
Live demos, you never know.
Let's try it out once more.
Something's going on here.
I'll try out the question draft.
It's not working, but
luckily, I have a video
of what it was supposed to do.
Sorry about that, everyone.
Always have a backup.
So this is what it
was supposed to do.
Live demos, you never know.
So it's supposed to predict
Matplotlib in Pandas
for this question.
And then we have a question that
I've drafted based on the code
that I wrote.
And it predicted
Keras for that one.
I'm sorry that the
demo didn't work.
Let's give it one more shot.
It looks like it's not working.
Anyway, that's what the
demo was supposed to do.
If we could, go
back to the slides.
So I covered a lot of
different tools today.
I just wanted to give a
summary of everything we built.
We built a custom text
classification model
using tf.keras.
We deployed our model
on Cloud AI Platform.
I should also mention
that I could have also
deployed that SHAP code to AI
Platform using the custom code
feature.
But in this case, I decided
just to keep it super simple
and do that part separately.
We explained our
model output using
SHAP to make sure that our
model was behaving in the way
that we expected.
And we kind of called AI
Platform with Cloud Functions.
You saw a video of what
it was supposed to do.
These are links to all of
the code that I showed today
and all of the
different products.
So the first link
goes to a GitHub repo
with the code for
everything I showed.
The other links are to various
products that I covered.
And finally, we are working on
model interpretability support
in Cloud AI Platform.
So if you have a
use case for it,
if you want to stay in the
loop and hear more about it,
we'd love to hear from you.
So please fill out this form at
the Bit.ly link at the bottom.
And finally, please fill out
the feedback on this talk
in your I/O application.
I really use that a lot to make
the talk better the next time.
So thanks, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]